lui c'est sûr qu'il en est pour toi ça
bat sa tête de mon père plus uni et plus
c'est grave
s'il se met à fumer c'est qu'ils me
foutent ue bingo il se souvient ses deux
enfants pauvres qui partent à la
recherche de l'oiseau bleu je veux faire
du théâtre qu'il assuma
[Musique]
pourquoi lorsqu'il a su qu'il a des
pouvoirs masi je crois qu'on peut
apprendre à devenir courage il veut même
guérir des maladies pour toi c'est toi
si tu retires ailes en plumes peyriac et
rieux
enfin je suis contente que tu sois sympa
ouais
[Musique]
oh
ne pas déguiser maman c'est beaucoup
trop flashy perdrix la route pour aller
chercher à l'école
[Musique]
soif histoire où l'on me prononcer
un moment difficile mais je serai là
messieurs des clubs phares défense
qu'est-ce que ça
tout est vivant
[Musique]